il y a des matins plus difficiles que
d'autres et aujourd'hui à Paris même si
les travailleurs pressés sont en plus un
peu déprimés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
prend sa retraite internationale
l'attaquant français l'a annoncé sur ses
réseaux sociaux en publiant cette photo
de lui prise lors d'un match de l'équipe
de France j'ai écrit mon histoire et la
nôtre prend fin a-t-il déclaré Hollywood
et Spielberg ne sont rien à côté de ces
bleus et de Deschamps nous sommes des
génies disons-le alors merci Didier
merci Kylian merci Olivier merci Antoine
la France est quand même repartie du
Qatar avec un record du monde celui du
plus grand nombre de tweets en simultané
24 400 messages par seconde au moment du
deuxième but de Mbappé
57,5% des utilisateurs de Twitter
veulent Kelon musk quitte la direction
le niveau patron avait lancé un sondage
en ligne sur le réseau social il avait
promis de se soumettre aux résultats de
ce vote sonner après le coup de sifflet
final les yeux dans le vide
abattu sur le banc français
ni les mots de ses coéquipiers
ni ceux du président de la République ne
suffiront à réconforter le numéro 10 à
l'opposé la joie immense de Lionel Messi
qui soulève sa première Coupe du monde à
35 ans seul titre qui manquait à son
palmarès la presse internationale se
demande comment il a pu se retrouver sur
le terrain à consoler Mbappe les
internautes eux soulignent un dribble
impassible du joueur pour ne pas rentrer
dans un jeu récupérateur et compare le
président à un gros lourd en boîte de
nuit vous imaginez le général de Gaulle
avec Philippe Gondet en 1966 après une
défaite contre l'Angleterre on a perdu
je crois 5-0 vous imaginez François
Mitterrand avec Michel Platini à Séville
je crois qu'on a basculé en fait on est
maintenant il n'y a plus que l'image en
marge de cette finale en France les
forces de sécurité ont procédé à 227
interpellations dont 47 à Paris
notamment sur les Champs-Élysées
incident signaler également à Lyon
matin belle brochette de pommes de terre
c'est je ne sais pas ce que c'est
je salue vous savez moi je suis tous les
messages des tirs de mortier des jets de
projectiles sur les forces de l'ordre
place Bellecour à Lyon des violences
urbaines ont eu lieu après la défaite de
l'équipe de France aux abords de la
place des magasins ont été détériorés et
des automobilistes ont été prises à
partir le chef de l'État rejoint
aujourd'hui le porte-avion français
Charles de Gaulle pour la traditionnelle
fête de Noël avec les soldats français
je suis donc venu partager un peu de
temps avec vous
d'abord parce que je suis heureux et
fier d'être parmi vous et aussi pour
saluer votre engagement les joueurs de
l'équipe de France qui descendent cette
nacelle avec Kylian Mbappe en troisième
position toujours avec le masque Gilles
le masque et les deux étoiles il y a
plus trois il n'y a pas trois étoiles
brodées sur leur survêtement ni même sur
leur maillot
issus de tous les horizons de la société
française vous êtes individuellement et
collectivement parmi les meilleurs au
monde dans la maîtrise de cet art
complexe mais nécessaire que la mise en
oeuvre du naviation de combat en mer et
à partir de la mer et j'en suis fier pas
d'objection adopter
c'est en pleine nuit peu après trois
heures du matin à Montréal que cet
accord historique a été approuvé à la
COP15 le compromis trouvé intègre un
objectif inédit protéger 30% des terres
et des maires de la planète décide 2030
un progrès significatif à ce jour seul
17% des terres et 8% des mers sont
protégés 2 millions 450 000 euros notre
chiffre du jour le prix auquel s'est
vendu ce week-end l'extraterrestre le
plus connu du cinéma ity ou plutôt sa
figurine articulée utilisée dans le film
culte de Steven Spielberg